on
bonjour et bienvenue sur une forme
federico votre coque
je suis accompagné aujourd'hui des devis
oui la vie octobre comme d'habitude on
essaye à l'euro un mouvement aujourd'hui
qui va cibler vos triceps et assemble
abdominale 1 2 en à perte
tu vas faire ça tous les jours bon je te
montre et après tu veux avec moi ok la
position elle assise avec deux as
histoire que tu peux trouver pierres
bouteilles d'eau ce que vous voulez de
support de boîtes de conserves les pieds
bien à plat on pousse les épaules vers
le bas et on va se relever pour
travailler sur les triceps
on ramène un genou vers la poitrine on
repose la jambe et au dessin exige
vibrer allez on va s'asseoir on met les
pieds bien à plat
tu va placer ses mains en face de tes
hanches étroites voilà on va tous et les
étoiles vers le bas et fait une poussée
vers le haut donc là on a une grosse
participation des triceps pour en faire
deux trois d'affilée dans mon temps en
descendant se fait de ce mouvement là on
travaille bien l'arrière du vin d'accord
nous ressemble
ouais on va rajouter mais non deux
montées de genoux quand on est en l'air
ont rompu genou on sent un contraction
de la sangle abdominale
je propose est en relâche j'en fais 3 à
l'aise partie
on pose et or l'âge allait peut être
cernée les jambes donc le but est
vraiment de travailler le 2 en 1 et 7 du
tableau on va faire un étirement
maintenant adapté aux bras d'accord sur
le triceps
on va se relever donc le mouvement on va
étirer les triceps
je me poste à madère son coude et tu me
ramènes derrière la tête en tirant
lentement vers la gare le but de cet
étirement est vraiment de métier tout
est le triceps tu le ressens ou même
toutes ces zones là tu peux aller
chercher un petit peu plus en arrière
super vous pouvez toujours retrouver des
étirements et des exercices
complémentaires sur les anciennes
émissions donnent une forme
merci juge la prochaine allez à bientôt
sur une forme lifton blocks les muscles
sollicités sont les abdominaux et les
triceps
entraînez-vous trois à quatre fois par
semaine en effectuant cinq à huit séries
de 15 avant répétition poussent et bien
les épaules vers le bas durant cet
exercice